[Music]
there is no firm agreement on the
definition of a sports car
although most experts agree it is a car
that can be driven on the daily chores
through the week
and raced on the weekend that was walter
cronkite
60 years ago racing up the lime rock
park in connecticut lime rock is one of
the nation's oldest and most historic
tracks
a paul newman favorite too today it's
owned and operated by a racing legend
skip barber now in his eighth decade
barber who has barely slowed down is
currently navigating the pandemic
while shepherding a new generation of
drivers into one of america's
great pastimes today more than half a
million americans drive sports cars
several thousand of them race walter
cronkite's exploration of sports cars
came during the peak of hot rodding
take a corner like that you see it you
really can put your foot in it get up to
speed in a hurry
when tens of millions of americans
tinkered with cars and garages
before racing them on suburban streets
and professional tracks
by the thousands they come on weekends
to watch the richer and braver at
courses like this one at lime rock
connecticut
one of the best destinations then and
now
is lime rock park in lakeville
connecticut
first opened in 1957 lime rock has been
owned for 37 years now by skip
barber a former race car driver who
became the most famous
instructor in america racing legends
jeff gordon
and chip ganassi are just two of the
renowned graduates from his school
when you were first up and coming their
belief was that you couldn't necessarily
teach someone how to drive the right way
and you disagreed with that yeah it
might be more accurate to say
there was no belief i mean it just
almost didn't occur to people i mean all
other sports had so many coaches
there was really one racing school at
the time and i didn't know there were
two
and i didn't know anything about them
and so when i started the school i
didn't know if it would work
and of course you can coach people
fortunately
fortunately barber drove home the idea
that drivers needed to pay attention to
the basics
like the key in all racing finding the
proper line
that means hugging the corners just the
right way hitting so-called apex
points on turns obviously the objective
is just to get the car through each turn
as fast as it
possibly can go there's a simple beauty
to it that has long lured in some of
america's biggest celebrities
james dean james garner and paul newman
who became a renowned driver after
beginning his racing career at the age
of 47.
newman's fascination with racing and
lime rock was featured in the 2016
documentary
winning you can drive hard and you can
even drive extra hard
and you're not going to win any races
the only way that you're ever going to
win a race is just to
be right on the edge of it all the time
i remember paul newman
talking about how he couldn't dance
couldn't sing couldn't hit a baseball
couldn't do anything
yet he could really drive a car why did
newman love this place so much
this is a very satisfying track to drive
if you get it right
so that was a big reason but people
really left them alone here
he could come here like a normal person
and he could interact
with people that it was about cars it
was about racing it's not what movie he
was going to make
and he wasn't bothered limerock has made
its name in part by not having any
grandstands or seats
people move around and enjoy what is a
park and not just a track
just watch how the corvair stays under
control in this situation
it's also a popular testing site for
automakers
[Applause]
as they get to try out the next
generation of cars the continued focus
on electric
are you driving or am i driving you're
driving we went out with barber
in porsche's new all-electric ticon
go for it good good good you can start
opening the throttle
let's unwind the wheel a little good
this is your only time to relax here
anything but a traditional sports car
not really one at all
the car is not a sports car but the
steering is
very much like the steering in a sports
car but a huge part of what appeals to
kids today
get to the apex and let it go this thing
really accelerates yeah it is
about 20 years ago we were really
worried about
the future of racing and everybody here
had gray hair
the people driving the people working
the spectators
and that has changed remarkably and we
would like to take credit for that but
we have no idea why that's happened
there's been a turnover i mean there's a
lot of young kids who are into it
they're not working on cars i mean you
know that when when this sport really
started in the 50s and 60s
kids worked on their cars you know hot
rodders all that and of course
you open a car hood now and forget it
but you come to a major spectator race
the place is full of kids
[Music]
it's not just the spectator or track
experience that gets the next generation
going though
passing through a beautiful countryside
like this just as it did 60 years ago
it's a chance to be outside on the open
road you got a country lane like this
one
before the thing really goes whether
it's a car powered by gasoline
or electricity feeling wind and speed
not just bumper-to-bumper traffic or
cramped office spaces
is as enduring as it gets this is
correct this is going to be our best one
as skip barber has been teaching for all
these years
this is good this is good don't turn it
anymore perfect
do you still find the same joy in
driving yes
never went away correct and
uh interest in cars never went away
that's right lime rock unfortunately had
to close now for races because of the
pandemic but they are open for
some private events responsibly um how
fast did you get
i went out with a couple different
vehicles um i don't know exactly um
of course you do come on come on
[Laughter]
uh probably fast that i should have at
times but um but that's why you have
people like skept to sort of
reign you in and teach you how to do it
the right way yeah
run off the track because it's not good